so we have the other realm which is our
soul and um you know and for me it's the
other realm is also
um other beings my my deceased loved
ones and I do feel guided all the time I
feel I'm communicated they're
communicating with me and guiding me all
the time and they're trying to
communicate and when I say they I'm
talking about either our higher self our
soul our guides our deceased loved ones
they try to communicate and guide us all
the time but we have to be open to it so
that's one reality then here in the
physical
I've I feel that we have almost become
like two worlds there is the world that
is living in fear and then there is the
world that can see through the fear
those are the two worlds that are here
so I choose not like heaven and hell
could you call that heaven and hell yes
you you pretty much could so Heaven and
Hell exist right here on Earth it's not
in the afterlife it's right here on
Earth
um and the afterlife is I just call it
pure love pure Consciousness but Heaven
and Hell Is Right Here and hence the
title of one of my books is what if it
what if this was Heaven in other words
you can choose to live in heaven right
here so Heaven is seeing through the
fear hell is living in the fear the
people that live in the fear they live
in the fear because there is a fear of
things like a fear of scarcity they live
in a world of scarcity a world of
competition there isn't enough to go
around so I have to get ahead of
everybody else they live in a world of
um where we are victims we're victims of
our reality victims of illness
um the thing is even illness it doesn't
happen in a vacuum it happens because of
the seeds you sow and you can reverse it
so but we're not taught all that the the
way that the medical model is designed
it's designed to make us feel that we
are victims of our illness and we're
helpless to them so
um so covid really really
um really pounded that that
um that in us a lot so um and edu the
education system as well you know it's
about it's about
um getting ahead of everyone else in
your class so when you see through the
fear you realize that there is more than
enough to go around but you just have to
be able to see through the fear to to be
able to access it when you see through
the fear you realize that collaboration
Mission works better than competition it
gets all of us ahead faster but
unfortunately the fear is so entrenched
in some people that the more you have
people that see through the fear
the more fearful
the fear-based people become so the more
they push the fear-based agenda and hold
on to it tighter and that's what I see
happening in the world today but I
choose to align myself with the people
who see through the fear yeah yeah it's
it's my own experiences have shown me
how things aren't just separate they're
part of the same whole so it's kind of
like almost like a teeter-totter where
it's like we're all part of the same
whole and the more people you know like
have you know are elevating and going oh
this is you know the see I see through
the fear it sinks the other side and
it's sort of like you know it's a could
be a teeter-totter it could be just um
uh expanding bubble of polarity that's
really actually
continuous and and and connected yes but
it does feel like there's just this sort
of expanding and Contracting of emotions
and experiences and there's one on each
side because it we live in a time where
you could say like oh my there's so many
perspectives that you could have that
are like oh everything is so bad there's
so much corruption there's so much this
but then you can also look on the other
side and go like we can have this
conversation and people understand like
uh we can there is so many more people
that are seeing through things we're
seeing the truth which is always going
to set you more free and so there's a
lot of actual like extremely Progressive
and enlightening and wonderful things
happening but there's also the other
side of it
um
I wonder uh like as we're talking about
sort of determinism and Free Will and
soul contracts what about
prayer and what about the power of it
and whether or not we can alter
timelines or Futures based on that
yes absolutely so it's both prayer and
meditation and group prayer and
meditation is very powerful to me so I
tend to organize a lot of group
meditation I do that to uplift the
planet to so it starts with uplifting
yourself because again if you're not
uplifted the people around you are going
to feel it so group energy so whether we
call it prayer whether we call it
meditation we are essentially doing the
same thing we are sending out positive
vibes and positive intentions to the
world we're expanding our own energy so
this is actually what's happening
whether it's prayer or meditation you're
actually expanding your energy and
you're sending it out into the world so
when people come together and do this
um I'm going to say when people come
together in the same time and space it's
super powerful but although time and
space is really compressed looking at it
from the other realm but yet I still
feel the energy of it when I bring a
group of people together when I actually
I either do it sometimes online or I do
it physically I put a shout out and I
say hey I'm going to be here who wants
to join me for a group meditation to
uplift the planet and the meditations
that I do tend to start with let's all
start with expanding our own energy
let's all see see ourselves as being
full and whole and healed and loved and
so we start with that so we feel good
about ourselves and then we expand it
outward
um I really feel that if more and more
people if more kids learn to do it if it
was part of their morning ritual when
they get to school with the whole school
does it as a morning you know a morning
prayer or morning meditation I think we
could change the whole planet I really
do if you were to call the shots on what
some I don't know top three top five
changes that would be the most
influential to shifting our planet into
a new
frequency State of Consciousness what
would you do
so if it were up to me I would want
everybody to to change their value so
for example right now if you look around
the world Cutting Edge technology
invention every form of progression
every former the way we're evolving the
number one value that it's based on is
money it's based on money that that is
behind everything
um like if you think about medicine if
you think about health care the bigger
factor is the money and not the
individual person's health if you think
about education teachers aren't getting
paid as much as they should considering
they're molding young people's lives
like the biggest Factor behind every
single evolution in in this in our
current modern world
is money the biggest driving Factor so
let me put it that way the biggest
driving factor is money if we shifted
that and if we made well-being the
well-being of humanity the biggest
driving Factor behind everything we do
our reality would change just like that
just like that because that was the
biggest shift I made in my life was that
I made my personal well-being the
biggest value of my life so everything
that I did everything that I
um moved forward doing it wasn't about
does it bring me more money does it uh
does it you know is this a good career
move none of those decisions mattered it
was like what does it do for my
well-being and once I made that shift my
life just changed moving forward and I
believe that if everything that Humanity
did was based on the well-being of the
people then it would change dramatically
and if I can just expand on that just a
little bit that we have cutting-edge
technology that exists but it's not
public knowledge it's not even
cutting-edge technology for healing for
healing cancers but it's not being
approved by governments to be used
because even though this is technology
that exists it's been done by scientists
it's been researched but it's not being
approved because it will
um it will actually cause the current
Paradigm the big money-making machine of
pharmaceuticals and the current research
and the current technology it would
cause that Paradigm to lose money and so
new technology is not released at the
pace at which it's being developed it's
being released at the pace at which the
people who make the money are willing to
relinquish yeah or at the pace in which
they can find a way to monetize it
exactly yes so it's being really least
at the pace I like that that's a much
better way of phrasing it it's being
released at the pace at which people can
find a way to monetize it but if we put
well-being ahead of money
it would be a very different reality if
you like this clip and you want to hear
the whole episode click at the bottom of
your screen
[Music]